there's the environment and I think that
I can summarize it quickly one in doubt
err on the side of the planet there's
still some scientific question I don't
think there's any more scientific
question about global warming there is
some scientific question about man's
contribution to global warming and how
much is generated by us I think that
that uncertainty has created too much
political indecision when in doubt err
on the side of the planet may be too
late in fact the the who's the British
fellow who founded the Gaia hypothesis
james lovelock or something he believes
is it's too late what if we had a chance
it would be a radical shift in our
energy consumption either radical
reduction we can't i'm a big fan of
alternative energy i don't think we can
get there fast enough I'm a pro nuke
environmentalist I think we have any
chance it would be through a rapid
development of nuclear power but and I
think politically that's not going to
happen because of the United States
because of the NIMBY syndrome so I'm not
I think that one of the two big
international issues is in the
environment and I'm not happy about our
chances and really winning that in the
next 50 years and by then it will be too
late if it's not now and then the other
is the Middle East I think that the rest
of the world pretty much plays by a set
of rules that everybody knows it's a
little bit like in corporate law there's
a court in Delaware called the court of
Chancellery or something and everybody
already knows how it decides things got
this very stable system and that means
the lawsuits rarely have to go all the
way in Delaware because it's so
predictable everybody knows how it's
going to be decided and so they save all
them themselves all those transaction
costs in international competition
that's basically the case throughout the
world other than the Middle East and the
Middle East is such a
such a well I'll put it this way i
really think that there's three groups
that are that matter in the Middle East
and it's not the religion rly the Middle
East conflicts as a religious conflicts
if you're going to get kids to blow
themselves up with dynamite you need a
beer jingle and the beer jingle can be
just different jingles for the different
kids but the real issue in the Middle
East is there's crooks and there's
fanatics and there's a small number of
moderates and we back the crooks because
we're trying to read the United States
back the crooks because we're trying to
get them we think that they're fighting
the fanatics for us in fact we don't
understand that the crooks and the
fanatics have a relationship of all
scratch your back if you'll scratch mine
in the process we're overlooking the
small but it exists the small moderate
class and if there's any hope in the
Middle East it would be finding them and
working them in sort of building civil
society around them but don't hold your
breath
me